il devait à l'origine être 7 mais
finalement seul 4 chefs d'État africains
seront du voyage Cyril Rama posa pour
l'Afrique du Sud Macky Sall pour le
Sénégal Akane
président des Comores et de l'Union
africaine formeront l'équipe de
médiation il rencontreront d'abord
volody mirzelenski vendredi à Kiev puis
Vladimir Poutine le lendemain à
Saint-Pétersbourg une initiative saluée
par le Secrétaire général de l'ONU il
s'agit d'une initiative importante basée
sur la bonne volonté d'un certain nombre
de pays significatifs mais quel message
portera cette délégation par le passé
les pays africains ont montré leur
division en février 30 votes en faveur
d'une résolution appelant la Russie a
retiré ses forces armées d'Ukraine 22
s'abstiennes et de votre contre au sein
même de la délégation le gouvernement
sud-africain a récemment rappelé
l'amitié qui le lie à la Russie alors
que la Zambie elle penche en faveur de
l'Ukraine
selon la Fondation Brazzaville à
l'origine de cette médiation le but est
plus économique que politique la
médiation vise à obtenir des accords
pour libérer les cargaisons de céréales
et d'engrais en direction de l'Afrique
atténuant ainsi le risque potentiel de
famille sur le continent
quelques jours avant ce voyage Vladimir
Poutine a menacé de bloquer l'accord de
juillet 2022 sur les exportations des
céréales ukrainiennes le Kremlin
reproche à Kiev de ne pas respecter les
exportations des engrais russes un sujet
qui animera les discussions menées par
la délégation